[Music]
when a young man was found dead of
suicide in a Massachusetts parking lot
three years ago his cell phone led to a
disturbing discovery it revealed the
teens girlfriend not only suggested he
take his life but appears to have
pressured him to follow through in a
series of text messages
the young woman Michelle Carter is
charged with involuntary manslaughter
her trial resumes on Monday CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Kleman is closely
following the case and she joins us now
Ricky good morning good morning so in
this case 20 year-old Michelle Carter
has been charged with involuntary
manslaughter again in the death of
Conrad Roy what can you tell us about
the case as it stands thus far if we
look at the facts of the case it's the
question of do the facts equal the law
so what happened is you have a 17 year
old girl involved with an 18 year old
boy over a two-year period they
exchanged thousands of text messages but
as it gets closer and closer to the time
of this young man's death she encourages
him cajole him taunts him mocks him into
committing suicide this is a boy who was
depressed who was suicidal she gives him
sites to look at ideas about suicide and
the worst part of it from the
prosecution point of view is that when
she has talked him into doing this by
carbon monoxide poisoning in a car he is
on the phone with her and it goes on for
a period of time where he gets out of
the car because he's too scared and she
stalks him to get back into the car to
finish the job stays on the phone with
him doesn't call anyone hears him cry
out till his death Ricky how unusual is
it for someone to be charged with
manslaughter were not actually
physically present at the time of death
very very unusual almost unheard of this
is a case of great importance in the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts but it
will also be of great importance
throughout the country because what you
have here is someone who is considered
virtually present and that's in the same
way of her being miles and miles away
but through her pushing him through
these texts through her malicious intent
that what she is basically done has been
next to him virtually and put the gun in
his hand so they decided in
Massachusetts to charge her with
involuntary manslaughter so tell us how
that all factors into the fact that
she's not being charged with assisted
suicide but involuntary manslaughter
well in Massachusetts what you have is
one of eleven states that does not have
a law that makes it a crime to do
assisted suicide so the only thing left
for the prosecutor if they wanted to
charge her with anything was this choice
of involuntary manslaughter it's also
the reason that they've gone forward in
this case from the defense and decided
to go forward with a bench trial not a
jury trial because a jury would look at
this case the way I sound and the way
you look which is this is just terrible
this is one of the worst things I've
ever heard of but a judge might be
dispassionate enough to say what is the
law how do I follow the law
Ricky prosecutors have played videos of
Conrad Roy expressing hope in some cases
disparaging himself in others what are
they trying to do with these videos the
videos I think were very important to
the prosecution for two reasons number
one is he's not a nameless faceless
person he comes alive on the video
number two is and really important he
has hope in these videos he is a kid who
is definitely depressed has problems but
you can see the hopeful side of him he
got a job he got into school that he
wants to live he's a life for saving
Ricky and Michelle Carter's lawyers were
hoping for an acquittal on Friday they
did not get one where do we go from here
well it's in the defense case now and
the defense is going to try to say that
this is young man who would have
committed suicide anyway it's a suicide
case not a homicide case Ricky cleamen
thanks so much for being with us this
morning